I want to draw a square. I would like to, I've got some Dotty paper on,
on the Brown paper here, so I can draw stuff on these dots.
I'm going to draw a square,
but I'd like you to tell me how big a square to draw.
Uh, let's do, uh, like a four by four.
So you called it a four by four.
How big is that square in terms of area and not a trick question and just
curious.
Oops. 16 units, 16.
Units. So it is possible to draw a square of so 16. And I want to say size,
I'm going to talk about area from now on, uh, 16 units.
What other squares are possible to draw on this grid?
And the rule is I've got to use the dots and straight lines between dots.
I don't think this is a trick question,
but can you suggest another square size I could draw?
Well, you could do like a two by two.
Every four. Yeah. So we do four. We can do 16 obvious ones, a one,
a one window, one. Uh, do you see the sort of numbers where we're getting here?
Always square. Now we're getting square numbers because we're drawing squares.
And first of all, that's not a surprise. The naming is a good thing here.
So I could draw a one, a four. I could do a nine. We didn't do that.
It's not a surprise that you can draw a square number, size squares.
Can you draw a square or could it could one draw a square on this grid using the
same rules during the dots? There's not a square.
Like diagonals or something. Oh.
Slightly squares that are allowed. As long as we stick to the dots,
let's try one. Um, I'd like you to tell me I'm going to start at this dot.
I won't go along the vertical or horizontal though.
So w where do you want me to go?
I can go a certain amount down a certain amount of long.
Four down.
To three. Ah, so four down here and an angle.
And go across to cross to.
If that's the side of the square, I better do this one sort of for long. So we,
it was definitely a square.
And you asked me to go sort of four down and too long,
which means all of the triangles like that. So there's a two, there's a four,
there's a sort of, so maybe we call it the two, four square and what's his area.
I don't think this is much less obvious to me now,
but it's not too hard to work out. There are many ways you could do it.
You can chop it into bits and work out the area of the beds.
Or you can look at the area of the big square,
which I think is six by six.
So 36 and take away the four triangles.
So I think he's trying to two by four, let's call it half times, two times four,
which means it's one times four, which means four. And here all together,
four times four is 16. So I think this is area 20 good.
So we've drawn squares on the grid that are not just the square numbers.
So I guess the natural question, it's a pretty elementary starting point.
What squares can you draw? We can definitely do square numbers.
We can definitely do the number 20. Could we, for example, work our way up,
we can do one. Can we do two tens out two is really easy.
You can see that each two triangles makes one. So this is area two,
and you do the same trick with the outside square, realize that's area four.
And you've got to have that anyway. Can you do three?
This is suddenly not obvious.
And you start drawing stuff and ends up being very hard to draw three.
At least even if it's possible, it's not easy to do.
And I think you can then convince quite quickly that it can't be done,
but we know we can do, can we do five? Let's try it.
It can't be a vertical horizontal one.
So we're going to have to go a bit of a slanty thing.
And if I go to down a one along, so the Square's going to look,
let's give myself some space that sort of diagonal,
which you can see is like a two and a one sort of vector. So the other side,
it was going to do that.
And that as long as I do a two and a one on each vector,
I'm pretty sure that's five. Then I enjoy the, the thing around it,
which is now nine, because it's three by three. And these triangles,
if I calculate them, let's do it. This is two and a one.
So the area of one, the whole thing is nine. The four triangles,
give me four. So this is very fine. Okay. So there's the problem.
The problem is even if you allow slanty squares,
which was your genius idea to door, to the square numbers, some of you can do,
you can do five and you do 20. You can do 10, but you can't do three.
The question I want to investigate in this video, which squares can you draw?
Um, is there a shortcut of finding what the areas that you could get?
So 20 took us a little bit of calculation with some triangles.
The five took us a bit, but I did. I used some other notations.
There's this two foreigners notation that when we're 20 and the two,
one notation from the five. And if we use the same notation,
this could be kind of like for zero notation,
because for every side you go along four and down zero,
I could write down all the lists of notation I could do. I could do one, one,
one, two, one, three, one, four, and I could just check all the lists.
And I could find pretty easily just by a search of all the numbers.
And they realized there were some missing. So three is missing. Six is missing.
Seven is missing. 11 is missing and already we're at a sequence.
I'm like an all prime. One of them is perfect. Yeah.
Like what's going on? I don't,
I really don't think it's obvious before we go any further though,
what would it be nice if first of all, we can find a shortcut for,
instead of having to draw a thing and count all the triangles,
how can I just write down the notation for the sort of slanting this and get
straight to the area I've,
I've seen this act activity done with sort of a nine year old school students,
and they're busy drawing squares and calculate it.
And they were having a lovely time,
but suddenly there's this deep glimpse of maths that goes way beyond what
they're ready for. Um, but what they are ready for is,
is finding a quicker way to do some area. So let me draw a general for you.
A slanty square is going to fit inside another square.
If I say that this distance is a, and this one is B,
then we've kind of got this. This is like our,
a B notation that we had you were describing earlier.
So my challenge is then how big is the square in the middle?
Cause that's the bit we can draw and it's not too bad.
I can work out the side of the big square.
Do you want to suggest how long that is? It's always going to be a plus. Yeah,
because there's the symmetry,
there's these triangles turn up all the way around.
So the whole square is a plus B squared. Happy with that.
What about the triangles?
Cause that was a way we did it before we can take away the triangles from that
and we'll get the area of this central bit.
And I think the triangle is relatively obvious is a and a B.
And there's a right-angle because the whole thing's a square.
So half of a times B. So if I subtract a four of them, four,
lots of a half a times B, right?
So that's the area where we're we're after we need to do some algebra.
So brace yourselves, I'm going to square this bracket. Uh, A-plus B plus B.
Let's just, just do the long way round to make sure we don't mess it up. Uh,
this is going to be a squared. We're going to get an a times a B, and again,
it'd be times and AYSO, but two lots of a B, and I'm going to get a B squared.
Uh, this will realize becomes two AB and actually,
I mean, this is a familiar bit of algebra, perhaps,
according to the calculation, though, uh, if you have an AB slant notation,
the area of this square is a squared plus B squared.
I suspect something familiar as a character loss.
People watching this video might be occurring to you as well,
but let's just check. It works.
The two for notation should give us 20 a square two,
you get four square four, you get 16. Add them together. 20, the two,
one notation square two, you get four square one. You get one added together.
You get five. It seems to work.
And it obviously works on the ones with zeros because fourth grade is 16.
No she's gone. Have you noticed what we just proved?
I mean,
if I put a C here and I talk about a right-angle triangle with size a B and C,
I'm saying the square on C.
We just proved by figures. Wow.
It's one of my favorite proofs by Faygo,
as it turns out in a way of playing with squares on a Dottie grid,
you ended up proving one of those facts of geometry that everybody knows.
There's literally hundreds of proofs for, but here's my favorite one.
And it kind of arises organically. I have a problem.
We were doing something else anyway. So bonus along the way,
we've proved by digress. We've now got shortcut.
If you've got an AB slanty square, a squared plus B squared,
which means the real question we're on now, which is for me,
which squares can you draw? And which ones can't you draw?
It becomes a number theory question, forget geometry.
It becomes which numbers can you make by adding two squares together,
we introduce the sum of two squares and the nine-year-olds I saw tackling this
problem. Don't make a lot of progress for this, because this is,
this is a classic piece of number theory.
There's out there in degree level undergraduate courses,
and I'm not going to solve it for you,
but let me write down at the beginning of the list of the squares that you can't
draw,
you can't draw three because there are no two numbers you can square to get
through. And if you try on the grid,
you end up drawing off the squares and very quickly,
or you've exhausted all the possibilities and all the answers you're getting
after that are bigger than three. So, you know,
the three is never going to turn up, so it can be done by exhaustion.
You just keep trying, you can't do six, you can't do seven. You can't do 11.
In fact, because it's an exhaustion thing,
you might as well do a computer program just to check sort of manually,
which ones can and can't be done.
So I'm going to boot up a computer just to get the list.
So this list of numbers is weird.
I'm going to just write down a few more of them. 12 is in there, 1450,
and you get a little run them consecutive there. Then it jumps in 1921.
That's enough for now these numbers, you cannot draw squares on Dotty paper.
Do they become more sparse or less pass as you go.
Up? I wonder.
I I'm. Well out of my depth there, the thing is,
and what's what was started as a simple problem.
Like I quickly get out of my depth.
This isn't a number theory question out of which numbers can be made as the sum
of two squares. And I have no intuition about it. Um,
what happened was I went and looked it up. I went and looked up,
which numbers can be the sum of two squares.
And it's a classic number theory problem that you'd do an undergraduate degree
in mathematics. And it turns out there's a,
there's a simple test which numbers can be made as the sum of two squares.
Do you want to know the test or do you, uh, do you want.
To get, I definitely want to know.
If a number has a prime factor of the form 4k plus the rate
to an odd power. It can't be done. Sorry, say that again.
I'll give you an example. The number 11, first of all,
this is prime one-line prime number.
And it, so it only has one factor.
It only has one factor, which is itself in one,
but the fact is other than one is just itself and it's a prime of the form
4k plus 3d by which I mean it's four times something.
And the three more equivalently is one less than the multiple of four. Um,
so you could say 4k minus one is kind of equivalent when you're going mod four,
it just cycles around every four. So these are the same thing.
It turns out all primes,
except two are of the 4k plus three type or 4k plus one.
And these ones, the problem is so three is another example.
It's one less than a multiple, uh, 19 in fact, seven as well.
These are all one less than a multiple of four.
Maybe prime numbers are not surprising and sequences like this,
but the six is what bothers people, because it's not prime.
It still can't be done. And that's because it has a factor of three,
six is three times two, in fact. And because it's has a factor of that form,
it can't be done before you get into it.
Nine has a factor of three is three squared.
So it has a factor of that form,
but because it's got two of them all play together fine.
So that number, the power has to be on for it to be a killer.
Exactly. So another killer one, let's pick one off the list. Uh, let's pick 12.
Uh, if we factorized, it it's two times, two times three,
uh, otherwise known as two squared, times three.
And the problem factor is a prime of that form. There it is.
And it's got an odd power.
So I'm guessing three times three times three. So 27.
27 Is three queued. Could it be done?
So it should be on the death list of ones that can't be done.
There it is. There it is. So this test is good.
And if we checked some other ones, so for example,
18 might be a good one to check.
We factorized that it's two times three times three.
It's definitely got a prime, which is three more than multiple or four,
but it's gone even power and 18 is not on the list. It can be done.
So there's some complicated interactions with the funerals.
If you want to investigate this,
which is a nice little accessible way of number theory to do,
then you can check. If you found one slanted square that works,
you can actually prove, works really easily,
that you multiply it by another slant is where the works.
Then you can build one. So it's to do with the multiplying,
which is why the prime is getting involved.
Because everything that comes from multiplying is coming from primes.
But if you want a very elementary starting problem,
where can you draw a square on Lottie paper that sort of escalates relatively
quickly into advanced number theory, which has an accessible proof,
but it's definitely much harder than nine-year-old maths.
This is a really lovely example of it.
Videos like this one always leave me wanting to get my brain in better shape.
And one way to do that is to check out all the online courses at brilliant.
The number theory course is a great place to start. You get some right,
you get some wrong, but that's okay. That's all part of learning.
And all the courses on brilliant have been crafted by people who really care.
They really think about how you navigate through these things,
how you will learn. Everything goes step by step.
You'll learn one new thing and that'll help you in the next bit.
There's loads of mathematics, science, all sorts of stuff to keep you occupied.
And there's more stuff coming all the time.
Have a look at these ones in the works,
go and have a look at the brilliant site. There's lots of stuff.
You can look there for free.
If you sign up for the premium membership that unlocks all the stuff,
you can get 20% off that by going to brilliant.org/number
file, we spend so much time exercising and getting our bodies in shape.
Brilliant is a great place to go to get your brain in shape.
Well,
the generation used to get taught that who probably was pretty much exactly the
ratio 22 over seven. It's not quite, but it's unreasonably good.
And you can see on this diagram,
that is unreasonably good because this is irrational,
but it's really well approximated by something to do with number 22.